the universe is everything from the
tiniest particles to the largest
galaxies to the very existence of
space-time and life but how did it all
begin the origin of the universe is the
origin of everything multiple scientific
theories plus creation myths from around
the world have tried to explain its
mysterious Genesis however the most
widely accepted explanation is the Big
Bang Theory the Big Bang Theory states
that the universe began as a hot and
infinitely dense point only a few
millimeters wide it was similar to a
supercharged black hole about 13.7
billion years ago
this tiny singularity violently exploded
and it is from this explosion this bang
that all matter energy space and time
were created what happened next were two
major stages of the universe's evolution
called the radiation and matter eras
they're defined by key events that help
shape the universe first came the
radiation era named for the dominance of
radiation right after the Big Bang this
era is made of smaller stages called
epochs that occurred within the
universe's first tens of thousands of
years the earliest is the Planck epoch
no matter existed in the universe at
this time only energy and the ancestor
to the four forces of nature the super
force at the end of the stage however a
key event occurred in which gravity
split away from the super force
next came the grand unification epic
named for the three remaining unified
forces of nature
this epic ended when one of those forces
called strong or strong nuclear broke
away then the inflationary epoch began
during which the universe rapidly
expanded almost instantly it grew from
the size of an atom to the size of a
grapefruit the universe at this time was
piping hot and it churned with electrons
quarks and other particles then came the
electroweak epoch when the last two
forces electromagnetic and weak finally
split off during the next stage the
quark epoch all of the universe's
ingredients were present however the
universe was still too hot and dense for
subatomic particles to form then in the
Hadron epoch the universe cooled down
enough for quarks to bind together and
form protons and neutrons in the lepton
and nuclear epochs the radiation eras
last two stages the protons and neutrons
underwent a significant change they
fused and created nuclei and in doing so
they created the first chemical element
in the universe helium the universe's
new ability to form elements the
building blocks of matter cused the
matter era much as the name suggests the
matter era is defined by the presence
and predominance of matter in the
universe
it features three epochs that span
billions of years the vast majority of
the universe's lifespan and includes the
present-day the first was the atomic
epoch in this stage the universe's
temperature cooled down enough for
electrons to attach to nuclei for the
first time called recombination this
process helped create the universe's
second element hydrogen
this hydrogen along with helium atoms
dotted the universe with atomic clouds
within the clouds small pockets of gas
may have had enough gravity to cause
atoms to collect these clusters of atoms
formed during the Galactic epoch became
the seedlings of galaxies nestled inside
those galaxies stars began to form and
in doing so they cued the latest and
current stage of the universe's
development the stellar epoch the
formation of stars then caused a
tremendous ripple effect and helped
shape the universe as we know it heat
within the stars caused the conversion
of helium and hydrogen into almost all
the remaining elements in the universe
in turn those elements became the
building blocks for planets moons life
everything we see today this ecosystem
of everything was only possible because
of the many stages in the universe's
development while countless questions
about the origins of our universe remain
it's only a matter of time for some long
sought answers to emerge
[Music]